welcome to this video playing a new
five-minute game against deck nips are
from Germany their clips on how do I
translate that hmm yar in this multiple
meanings of this actually yeah one
lesson from sports and in sports the
clips are the Eclipse IDE German means
the guy was scoring many goals like and
soccer ok we gotta be known here with
night to g3 and down is playing very
quickly b6 I don't know okay it's not
own trying to do anything against my
plans basically ignoring what i'm doing
i hope i can punish them here I think
should have done something against this
Bishop age six plan okay so it's I don't
know what he's trying to do you cannot
play be five I just just take it to take
it in more than one way actually okay
but anyway I want to get the King out of
this sensitive diagonal
you know the question is directly 5 + f5
now this would be the most aggressive
way to play this time I'm going for that
D 5 D tags and l5 the standard way of
attacking the serve this position to
this position I'm not one hundred
percent sure if I'm happen if I'm
perfectly placed to do that yeah this is
one of the ways to play against that is
black hmm not sure if I should take on
360 out save the should therefore just
saw that this is actually good 95 I just
take I mean take here and then take on
you for this is simple and good
I threatened d6 at the end should be
should be okay
mmm yep just Bishop g5 threatening
Knight f6 d6 doesn't lead to much
probably I should do that Knight f6 s is
a big threat it's not done something you
can ignore the Bishop of six maybe also
a threat yeah while I have five I can
just give this check and it looks
terrible I'm not sure what you should
play Knight g4
I can take it though and d6 coming I
don't know i don't see you move
door is innocent some tricky
I five but Knight f6 looks terrible I
cannot play a 5 I don't believe that we
made maybe he needs to but it's not a
move you want to play 97 yeah I just
thought about that covering covering f6
for the moment I don't think that now
giving this check needs too much
probably I should play d6 first yeah he
needs to go to the add the promise if it
goes to be 6f queen d 5 for this is a
disaster and now Knight f6 is really a
big discovery discovered check oh you
can just take it I overlook that yeah
well I hope there's some justice in this
and I'm still winning still looks rather
difficult with rook e8 coming yeah no
justice and this is probably the wrong
expression if I London blundering I
overlooked that before wasn't even
hanging but what now yeah this check
this check cannot be better really would
be amazing if it was
Wow
yeah of course I can just take here
Clady seven at the end
but shouldn't shouldn't there be a
direct win the sugar in their form or
something yeah what is he moving after
that Queen f7 this is pinned can just
take the aid
my queen f5 of course am but I can then
take and play d 7 winning the rook grab
the trip to power to e7 I just take see
it antic see it it's just a piece come
on this is easier and i'm still
threatening all the stuff we should be
seven and Bishop age 6
check and there should be seven others
should win really please check
check yeah this is czechian this is a
check I can take it everyone is hanging
check check Queen have six service and
what I should do Jack Jack draw oh yeah
of course Jeff Jeff time morning check
yet me Tony seven yeah yeah yeah I just
blundered on your phone I mean him down
maybe there are some ways to improve on
that taking won't be five first or so
but this really looks terrible f5 the
computer actually gives f5 are still
apply playable just 11.4 wide now this
is so totally winning bishop f3 is it is
even winning i didn't i didn't see it
really this let you can take a look at
this winning this is winning and now all
kinds of you're also taking on d three
wins but i hope this does win as well
yeah it does but Queen d3 is probably
easier check check check check check
yeah okay this is enough i have 20
seconds it was so was an unnecessary
repetition yeah but doesn't it doesn't
hurt anything alright thanks for
watching